The Joe Rogan Experience everything is
weird about this for me it's just like I
don't I'm just like I guess a socially
awkward kind of don't really put myself
out there well I do with fighting but
it's like I've never really put myself
out there in life so it's like to be in
these kind of positions it's just it's
all a lot for me wow well it's amazing
that the way you handle fighting you
could handle this the same way you
handle fighting you just get comfortable
with it I think that uh I don't know for
me social situations are a lot harder
than like fighting situations wow that's
crazy oh yeah like has it always been
like that 100 since you were a child
yeah I I feel like I've always been like
the like socially awkward kid in the
back of the class like the Nerds well I
still am like at the gym but um I
volunteered with animals my whole life I
uh volunteered at like an uh the Humane
Society a horse rescue uh wildlife rehab
but just like animals were my thing and
then it was just kind of a left field I
started kickboxing when I was 16. just
for fun yeah I really don't know where
it came like what the idea was but uh
where'd you start what gym at Dean's gym
oh yeah wow you got lucky so exactly uh
one of Dean's Pro Fighters worked for my
dad
so I wanted to start kickboxing and then
my dad found out that this guy was a pro
Fighter for Dean so he ended up finding
his gym and that was the first gym I
started at wow wow what a great place to
start and so then you start kickboxing
and how long before you decide well what
about this MMA stuff how long was that I
think
I think four or five months before I
started taking the MMA class there but I
wasn't like thinking about fighting it
was just uh there was a kid who's on the
wrestling team at my high school who
started training at Dean's gym and he
was like oh why don't you take the MMA
class and I thought okay I'll have a
partner why don't I try it and I just
kept on doing it and then I was training
like
every day for like three hours a night
you know and they're like all right well
why don't we just get you a fight at
this point
wow what was it about
fighting in martial arts that you became
so obsessed with
I think it was a when I I don't know
what it was at first because I didn't
start Jiu Jitsu especially in the ghee
until like a year after I started
training but when I started Jiu Jitsu I
fell in love with that 100 where it's
just the technique of it and the the
little tiny details of Jiu Jitsu that
matter so much like if you put your
thumb on this side of the hand or on
this side of the head it makes a huge
difference it's like the little tiny
techniques that can make the difference
where now 115 pound girl at the time
could do whatever she wanted to a 200
pound guy you know I was manhandling
these guys around the room and I'm like
just because these techniques that I
learned and I thought that was awesome
yeah that is an amazing thing it's Jiu
Jitsu is the one martial art that
delivers as promised where the smaller
trained person can defeat the larger
untrained person whereas a lot of other
martial arts
I mean you have a better chance but when
they're really big you know and some
guys swinging if he knows how to punch a
little bit and you get clubbed with one
of those giant hams you get [__] up
but if you get into a straggle like some
sort of a scramble and you knock into
some chairs and all sudden you get a
hold of this person oh now he's [__]
that's what's crazy it's like that a
small person can physically control and
submit a much stronger person regularly
it happens all the time it happens with
black belts even in Striking it's like a
person cannot know anything but if
they're big enough they throw their hand
the right way they can knock you out
yeah if you get hit with Francis and
gano's Pinky you're in trouble exactly
there's certain people they're so
powerful like the idea that you're gonna
stand and trade with them is going to
hit you once and you're dead you know
that's like it just doesn't work that
well Jiu Jitsu it's just there's the not
the uh variant of space so the there's
not that element of like guessing where
it's like I can control and I can feel
what you're gonna do by touching you
it's like it makes it a lot easier
you're not guessing with that space is
striking you're also not guessing the
variables like how fast is this person
how fast am I accustomed to people
punching me is this person much faster
do I have to anticipate that because if
you ever see like street fight videos
the most horrific ones are some poor
[__] who wants to start a fight with
someone who's a trained fighter and the
train fighter [__] them up but you
could see like they have no idea how
fast things can happen like you I'm sure
you've seen the Joe showing one yeah so
silly one's ridiculous but there's no
way that guy could have known that that
could happen that quickly there's no way
and people don't expect like like for
someone like me a lot of times I get oh
I would never guess that you're a
fighter for someone like Joe Schilling
is still even like oh yeah you wouldn't
like just say Max murderer well you just
see him walking around like most people
you don't expect that they're Joe
Schilling you don't expect it psycho to
me yeah yeah but say like Ryan Hall Ryan
Hall is a great example you know
you don't be a fighter but it's like you
never know what somebody's capable of
when it comes to sports like this oh for
sure what Jiu Jitsu Mikey musumachi yeah
exactly yeah Mikey is a stone cold
killer and he looks like a guy who comes
over to fix your computer like he's he
looks like the friendliest super nerd oh
this video is horrible this is street
fight in in a parking garage have you
seen this no
these guys start [__] with this dude
in a parking garage the guy's trying to
get away no he [__] the other guy up
before this this is the shorter version
okay this is a shorter version so this
guy he's trying he's like come on you
want some and he moves forward this guy
leg kicks him
and then this is where it gets ugly
punches them bam
yeah you don't want that like what like
it's it's it's awesome to see that stuff
works right for people like hey this is
real someone tries to attack you you
have an upper hand but also like what
are you doing yes [__] people uh I've
never been in a street fight in my life
good for you like I don't intend to ever
but
it's just I I don't get it like yeah
there's I I don't see a use for fighting
outside the cage for me like a lot of
people anger management issues and then
there's criminals too and you know bad
folks yeah exactly yeah there's a lot of
weird stuff in the world but I just for
me
um I think it's fascinating that you are
more afraid of social interaction that
you're afraid of cage fighting that
might be one of the greatest lines that
anyone has ever said I think that's
going to get you a lot of fans
for real for me it's just like literally
I never really uh did any kind of
interviews or Media or anything like
that until I got in the tough house so
that's going from absolutely zero to one
hundred percent like what was that like
you were like 22 at the time I was 22
and I was having interviews every day
cameras on you 24 7. literally after
every single interview I had to go and
change my shirt because I'd be dripping
sweat like I just got out the sauna whoa
just so nervous after every single
interview do you think they brought you
into the house knowing that you were
nervous too that like that you're a
little socially awkward in that regard
and like that maybe that would make good
television
but they also cast that show as a
reality show it's a very cleverly done
show you know like it's it's smart the
way they do it they like even with what
they're doing now with Conor McGregor
and Michael Chandler it's great but
perfect perfect [__] talking when Connor
tells them you'll do is your toes
it's amazing okay I hope that fight
takes place but it's it's such a it's
such a show right so it's not just an
athletic competition it's also they want
to make sure the people are fun oh yeah
our season seemed pretty like tame
though I feel like in general we had a
lot of there is me and Montana De la
Rosa were the two like younger girls and
then everybody else I feel like was like
older and more mature like around like
at least like 30s and like they were
like I don't nobody was trying to start
drama nobody was trying to like get in
each other's faces or we didn't have any
altercations it was like it was a pretty
chill season that's great so no one ever
encourages like any bickering or
anything like that they don't ever tell
you hey you know that's [__] has been
signing some [__] does anybody ever do
that no nobody ever really does anything
like that but it's just like the boredom
gets to you if anything else it's like I
feel like no phones right no phones no
TV no music no books no nothing books
nothing at all oh God nothing so it's
like can you have a notebook you're
allowed to get a notebook and then they
gave us we asked for coloring books and
they gave us sketch pad
oh my God I think I would go nuts that
sounds like one of those uh like
anti-tech Retreats you know exactly are
they trying to weed people off their
tech tech addictions I was just talking
to one of the boys who's actually on the
Conor McGregor season over the weekend
and he said the exact same thing as me
he's like it was the best and worst
experience of my life because it's like
when you're in the gym there's so many
highs it's so great but then when you go
back to the house you're just sitting
there for hours and you're bored and it
sucks
what do you guys do to kill time can you
play games do they have like I need they
used to have pool right yeah I think
they had a pool table and a chess table
and then they have like the list where
you can order anything oh so you could
order like Monopoly yeah so we would
order a bunch of [__] just try and
entertain ourselves God
people did you have good conversations
uh or was it weird because you're all
competitors it's weird well not because
they're competitors because I'm weird
that's awesome I'm like I felt like I I
especially back then I wasn't able to
just like I don't know acclimate to that
going into a house with 16 different
girls that I don't really know right
yeah that a completely alien experience
and you sell you're feeling a little bit
awkward and you're also 22. and then
also bam now you're on TV and it's my
first time like really like leaving home
I would say you know for a long period
of time so it was it was definitely a
big experience like a lot to take what
was that now
um six years six years yeah so what do
you would you say that now you're
entering into your fighting Prime do you
think that's happening right now oh yeah
I think this is like just the beginning
of my Prime I'm just getting into where
I've really found the right combination
for everything and I feel like I'm just
getting better every fight are you
ranked right now in uh where are you at
uh my next fight is against the number
15 girl uh Tabitha Ricky interesting
she's tough that'll be fun that'll be a
good one yeah I'm like it's coming up
quick June 24th oh wow that is quick